cinq ans il paraît qui joue bien au
tennis je vous réponde mettre un grand
coup droit des remaniements
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
car
là ils sont avec nous ce soir
applaudissements pour les bodin's
[Applaudissements]
kitty chauvet quel film n'est pas là
alors elle devenir delphine wespiser oui
et faire la sienne elle un tournage ont
fait pas son l'aiment bien nous et on a
rencontré les gens du voyage c'est la
seule en trente ans de fort boyard qu'a
réussi à redonner la gaule au père
fouras on est venu pour la
saint-valentin ratio mon gamin aurait a
un message à faire passer
je veux m'adresser à ça une seule
personne a les boules le gamin seule
personne qui prend une très grosse plage
dans ma vie et eux c'est très gros ici
sur 128 au café commencé à prendre la
place enlèverait par amour on déplace
des montagnes serait là c'est plus de
l'alfi
aujourd'hui pour la saint valentin j'ai
pris mon courage à deux mains
parce que faut pas remettre à demain jeu
qu'on peut faire à la saint valentin
piraterie siens j'en suis je pour mal je
me souviens de toi dans mon lit à
l'époque c'était le paradis
maintenant je suis tout seul avec ma
mère et crois moi tous les jours c'est
l'enfer fais gaffe quand même c'est
celle animée à l'évasion c'est la vie
chante oise mais que chagrin c'est comme
un grand feu qui s'est éteint comme un
bon repas change un bon vin mais vous
comme fort boyard champs les nains magie
les jaunes sont son rond point ça c'est
en bouche un coin de sa bouche un coin
c'est que ça me trouvais alors c'était
pas prévu mais du coup moi ça me donne
une petite idée simple pour arrondir mes
fins de mois
cyril hanouna vous de ratures mais
poussés
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
cinq ans il paraît qui joue bien au
tennis je voudrais pas mettre un grand
coup droit de remaniement
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
il ose les landes passe c'est oui
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]